in a world consumed by breaking news one
man has the focus to cut through the
president's losing a Twitter fight to
jewel to cut food Isis won Powerball who
sold them a ticket to cut this where are
kittens even getting opioids oh he did
the accent it's much more racist if he
did the accents a chipmunk attacked a
synagogue and he knew it was a synagogue
John Oliver is back to put aside
distractions and get to the bottom oh
wait Harambee again I literally don't
understand how that's possible did he
come back and then they got him again
was the same kid involved last week
tonight with Jeff this one just says run
last week tonight with John Oliver
returns Sunday February 18th on HBO
[Music]
[Applause]
you